Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan. And today, we
will continue the complete guide to Parca.
Before we go any further, let's set the
scene.
You are working on your million dollar application,
and is running in production to hundreds, thousands,
hundreds of thousands, or maybe even millions of
users across the world.
You need to understand how your application is
running
from metrics,
logs,
traces
and profiles.
Now, in our first video, we took a
look at profiling our application with Parker using
the Parker server, the Parker agent and the
Parker server UI.
However,
we don't really want our profile and information
to live in isolation.
It becomes a key component and our observability
stack.
We actually need to consume this information side
by side with our metrics, logs and our
traces.
We need a single pane of glass. Now
I hate
using that term.
Why? Because vendors have thrown it down our
faces for the last ten years trying to
sell us snake oil. So their products that
offer this wonderful magical experience to understand our
application.
But really Grafana is all you need. Grafana
can speak to your metrics back end, your
logs back end, your tracing back end and
now your profiling back end.
So in this video, I'm gonna show you
how to take those
Parca profiles,
add the Grafana plug in,
and how to debug your applications all without
leaving Grafana.
Let's take a look. Hello. And welcome back
to the Rawkode Academy. I'm your host, David
Flanagan. And today, we will continue the complete
guide to Parca.
So first, I have a virtual machine on
the cloud running the Parca server.
You can see here it is configured with
a test agent, which has been scraping for
a while now, as well as a static
config
scraping Parca itself.
We have a Parca agent, which will list
the different profilers.
Here we have the Parca agent CPU.
So we are consuming CPU samples with the
Parca agent for any process discovered via as
eBPF probe.
We can expand the process list here, see
everything that we need to see.
Now of course, we'll see the Parca agent,
we'll see our Grafana
and we'll see our million dollar application,
just like in the first video.
However, we don't want to do this with
the Parca UI,
nor can we do it with the Parca
agent UI.
So let's jump over to Grafana.
So this is a plain Grafana install. Nothing
tweaked to configure or installed yet.
So we're gonna go straight to data sources,
where we have the big blue button to
add a data source.
We can add this like so and type
Parca.
Now
what's really cool here is that Grafana themselves
have worked on a core plugin to support
Parca as a backend.
So you don't need to go and find
any third party ones to get them running.
You just click go
and enter your Parca URL
because these are running on the same machine
that's a local host seventy seventy.
Now I can hit save and test and
we expect a green check telling us this
data source is working.
Perfect.
And honestly,
that's it for the config part.
Go to data sources, click add, click save.
Could not be easier.
So let's scroll up and say, let's explore
this data source.
Now this is gonna function the exact same
as the Parca server UI.
You get to pick the profiler information that
you want. Here we'll grab from the Parca
agent CPU profiler
because this is the one doing auto discovery
on the node.
And we'll ask for CPU samples.
Now, I can just say show me the
last five minutes and click go.
And we'll see all of our applications running
on the host.
If we scroll down, we'll see right at
the top, we have my million dollar application.
We have the Parca server, my million dollar
application.
Some kernel stuff,
Parca.
And if we scroll down a little bit
more,
eventually we'll get to
any other application.
There we go.
Container d, Grafana,
Docker d, Lebessey and so forth. So currently,
we're viewing every single piece of profile information
that we have available from the Parca agent.
So let's reset our view.
Let's go back to the top.
Let's filter
on executable,
where we get an autocomplete list of all
the applications running on the host.
If we want to take a look
at Grafana,
we can type it in and say run.
If we want to take a look at
the Parca agent, we can do that too.
However, what we really want to see is
the same application
from the first video.
That is our million dollar
application.
So let's click run. Now we have the
c pro the CPU profile and information for
the last five minutes. Already,
we can begin to see some problematic functions
much like we did in the first video.
But let's just jump back over to our
terminal.
Where we can run a curl
HTTP
local host, eighty eighty,
I equals two
and j equals one.
Now this should return a response very quickly,
but it's not because we have a problem.
Our calculator is broken.
So, let's dig in.
Well, first, we have this nice little graph
that show us the CPU sample fluctuation.
You can switch it to a bar, points,
stack lines, stack bars, and so forth. All
the Grafana features that you're probably familiar with
having used it for such a long time.
We then have the profile specific information.
We can switch to just the top table,
just the flame graph, or both side by
side.
From the Stairs box, we can filter by
functions. If we have a rough idea of
what we think is wrong, then we can
establish that by saying, show me
just
the addition function.
This grays out everything on the right and
filters down to the function here.
From here, we can focus.
And we can see that for the
many many samples of the addition function, most
of the time is consumed with this fed
function
and then mem move
as well as
heap pointers
and grow slice.
So clearly,
something weird is happening within addition dependency or
Fibonacci function. There's some serious memory allocation or
memory movement happening.
And then after that, everything
kind of shrinks down showing us that they're
not actually consuming that much of our CPU
cycle.
So let's reset the view and without the
search this time, we'll do the exact same
thing.
We can see here that our total allocation
is up here. We have the serve function,
which of course is gonna take up more
the majority of the time because it is
an HTTP server.
And this is true for all of these
serve HTTP things all the way down.
Then we have some standard stuff happening over
here that doesn't really raise any red flags,
but of course, addition
Feb
setting here right before the yellow breakdowns, the
shrinking
of the icicles down the graph. Again,
highlight that we really need to focus our
time
here.
Specifically
on this fib and actually function.
That's when you would go to your code.
You would scrutinize every lane,
look for bugs,
run performance tests against it,
write new test cases, whatever you need to
do to establish what is happening and all
without leaving Grafana.
So that's getting started with Parca and the
Grafana plugin.
Like I said, this is a short and
sweet video.
It's very easy to get started.
You barely have to do anything and you
have your profile and information with the rest
of your observability
stack.
So
go have some fun. Profile applications with Parca
today. Add the Parca plugin to your Grafana.
When you see bad things happening from metrics,
logs and traces, correlate that with profiling information
from Parca.
Debugging has never been so much fun.
Till the next video. We'll see you soon.